[Music]
now to be totally honest with you i
wanted to do a big and epic cancellation
today as we head into the thanksgiving
holiday or at least as i head into it
because i won't be here tomorrow but my
plans for a grand and dramatic and
perhaps even historic segment were
derailed when i happened across this new
york post article and found myself once
again highly annoyed by something
relatively trivial the forces of the
universe have now compelled me again to
spend our remaining minutes together
talking about um this instead i can't
help it's not my fault it's this
person's fault as new york post reports
a distraught mom has taken to tick tock
saying that she feels like a failure
after learning her seven-year-old son is
a bully
now we'll pause there for a moment just
to say that um
we are already on the wrong foot anytime
distraught
and taken to tick-tock are in the same
sentence
there are many understandable things a
person might reasonably do when they're
distraught
even some understandable things they
might unreasonably do but making a tick
tock video is not one of them no sincere
stable person has ever felt truly
distraught and said to themselves oh no
i'm distraught this is terrible it's
tragic i'm devastated wait where's my
phone this will make a great tick-tock
vid
no sincere and stable people don't do
that which means that if you're doing
that you're either insincere or unstable
or both probably both anyway back to the
article it says
the mom named beth posted an emotional
video to the social media site last week
detailing the moment that she learned
her boy had attacked an overweight peer
while on board a school bus
i feel like a failure beth wrote beneath
the clip which has been viewed more than
1.5 million times
my son came home telling me another
parent threatened him for accidentally
knocking his son's glasses off his face
she explained i believed every word that
came out of his mouth
beth decided to speak with the school
bus driver after her son told her the
incident occurred on board the vehicle
and she was stunned by what she found
out next
quote the driver explained to me how
this child is heavyset and he can't get
off the bus quickly he told me how my
child was shoving this boy down the
aisle because he wasn't fast enough
my child ripped the boy's glasses off
his face and threw them to the back of
the bus
it's not funny um
it's not funny bullying is not funny
beth said that she was left heartbroken
after learning of the incident and it
really hit home as she herself had been
bullied about her weight when she was a
child
okay now in fairness to her son
you really shouldn't move faster when
you're getting off the school bus nobody
wants to be on that thing any longer
than they need to be
and i'm not sure how being heavyset is
an excuse here frankly i'm not condoning
what her son did especially because
there's a distinct possibility that this
woman is mentally ill and none of this
really happened
she might not even have a son the story
sounds
fabricated her son if she has one is
acting like the stereotypical bully from
like a 90s nickelodeon cartoon hey get
out of my way four eyes
i'm surprised he didn't give the kid a
wedgie and then peer pressure him into
smoking a cigarette out behind the
bleachers or something
but assuming this really did happen uh
we'll continue the post says
beth said she was left heartbroken after
learning of the incident and it really
hit home as she herself had been bullied
about her weight when she was a child i
do not condone this behavior and it's
not tolerated the mom said as she sobbed
on screen
i don't know where to go from here i'm
obviously doing something wrong the
emotional parent confessed
well i've got some ideas beth
about what you might be doing wrong but
before i share those with you let's take
a look at one of the viral tick tock
videos she made stemming from this
potentially fictional incident
um here's one where she addressed the
bully the bull she addresses the bullied
child directly in this video and lip
syncs an inspirational song to him while
weeping
you're not going to be able to
appreciate the sheer cringe of this
video unless you unless you see the
actual visuals so if you're listening to
the audio make sure to go over to
youtube or something and watch this
because you have to see it
uh here it is
[Music]
i promise you're enough
[Music]
you're not here enough
[Music]
do these people not have anyone in their
life
to stop them from doing this
do they not have anyone to say no this
is don't don't this the cringe here is
too much
that is a tough one to get through not
because it's emotionally affecting but
because of the nuclear-grade second-hand
embarrassment meanwhile she's totally
throwing her own seven-year-old son
under the bus on social media in front
of the entire world again assuming your
seven-year-old son exists
this is the real cancel offense
obviously if you find out that your
child has bullied another another child
you should dole out the appropriate
correction and discipline
you should handle the situation as a
parent but what you don't need to do and
should not do and shouldn't ever even
think about doing
is broadcast the situation on social
media
you shouldn't get the public involved in
your relatively routine parenting
situation
parenting is not a spectator sport your
child is not a public figure
you don't need to issue statements and
press releases if he gets in trouble at
school
you keep it private
if you feel the need to reach out to a
child that your bratty kid is bullied
reach out to him go to the bus stop and
talk to him call his parents whatever
you don't need to connect with him via
tick-tock video he's seven
he shouldn't even know what tick-tock is
and if he does he's got bigger problems
than a little scuffle on the school bus
this is a pretty widespread problem
these days parents who essentially use
their own children
as click bait
exploiting them for shares and likes
and it's not even clear to what end i
mean unless you make a living as a
content creator why do you care about
getting shares and going viral what good
does it do you
how do you benefit
well i suppose it satisfies the need
that satisfies the need for attention a
need that has grown ever stronger in the
human species more insatiable as our
lives are increasingly consumed by the
internet attention is the currency of
the internet it's the original
cryptocurrency
and some people many people are so
desperate to be rich in that kind of
bitcoin that they'll think nothing of
selling out their own children
anything for a small ration a small
taste of attention
anything for approval and affirmation
from faceless strangers who don't know
you or care about you and won't remember
your content 15 seconds from now
and that is why this woman whatever her
name is because i've already forgotten
which proves my point
is cancer
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends